book education is having a chilling
effect on Free Speech a good chunk of
conservative college students say they
self-censor their views inside and
outside of the classroom out of fear of
damaging their reputation 63 percent of
students overall fear speaking their
minds could have a damaging impact and
42 percent of conservative students
report that they often feel
uncomfortable speaking freely and just
this week Stanford tries to eliminate
harmful Language by Banning offensive
words like American but we have an
amazing update on that the woke college
is walking back their idiotic speech
code and updating their website with
quote to be very clear not only is the
use of the term American not banned at
Stanford it is absolutely welcomed so
Jessica I think actually conservatives
hiding their political perspectives on
college campuses if they're not
politically involved is actually not
something new yeah what is new is it's
one thing to write a paper from a
different perspective in a class and
argue with professor but if you're
having to do that outside of the
classroom among your peers that's a
different thing I could imagine it being
a very tough environment to do that to
just even with it's like a part of five
it's a very tough environment
um no because part of the problem is
also that everyone just talks about
politics all the time it wasn't that way
even when we went to college which
wasn't that long ago you know everyone
kind of loosely knew where your politics
lay but you had other stuff to talk
about whether pop culture stuff
relationship whatever it is and now it's
infiltrated I feel like almost every
aspect of our lives and that's what
makes it so much harder than for people
to be able to express themselves so you
should be able to go to a party see a
cute girl you go up to her talk to her
now she's going to say something like oh
you know are you participating in X Y or
Z activity and then it all comes out and
it's a problem yeah Trump really was a
line in the sand for a lot for a lot of
people and even for some Republicans who
just couldn't get on board with this
right it's not a traditional
conservativism
um to put it nicely um I think it's a
real shame and I think it's important
that people do spend time with folks who
don't think the same as them even if it
makes you sure of your beliefs so I I
hate this judge isn't on college
campuses supposed to be a place of
exchanging ideas debating learning how
to defend your own values you can't do
that if everybody's censoring themselves
yeah well you know it started with uh
Berkeley being supposedly the birthplace
of free speech until about six years ago
when conservatives dared to go to
Berkeley to speak and then it was like
you cannot speak we will burn down
Berkeley and we will smash every every
uh every window every door but the truth
is that um the kids are self-censoring
for good reasons they know that they're
going to be punished by their peers they
know they're going to be punished and
and not giving good grades by their
professor others and I think they
understand better than a lot of people
think that it's not the place for
dialogue and it requires that when
someone goes to college that they have a
really strong moral core and know who
they are or they're going to be swayed
right into the nonsensical politically
correct way of thinking and the
political the only political ideology
that you're allowed to express Sean I've
spent some time on college campuses as a
speaker being protested by Rowdy college
students but I get questions from
parents all the time about how to
prepare their conservative kids for
school you have lots of conservative
kids some of them have been through
college and they've been active as
conservatives on our campuses well I
learned the lesson that when I pay for
school I'm going to help pick the school
my kids go to I'm not going to send them
to these woke schools because they
professionalize indoctrinating your
children and they're very good at it and
I can lose my own kids so I try to send
them now I have so many kids I can get
it wrong and then get it right later but
I think it's important to note that all
these professors are very liberal you
don't have a conservative professors on
campus and judge you're right they're
concerned about being you know punish
whether it's their grades there they
could be you know canceled online they
can be kicked out of college for what
they say and I think it's great when you
have a you know a well-informed young
conservative debating a teacher that can
Inspire other kids to go hey really good
point I'm with this guy not the teacher
that's a great thing but I mean I think
this if you look at a threat to
democracy it's these universities that
are a threat to democracy 62 of college
students think it's acceptable to shut
down a speaker by yelling at them 20
think that they can use violence to shut
down speech this is crazy town for all
of us who used to go to school back you
know 10 20 30 years ago well that's like
the college campus atmosphere is the
Spilled Out into all sectors of society
Jimmy but as the comedian at the table
tonight let me say this yeah campus is
the worst place for comedians to go
because everybody is so offended this is
the irony and I don't mean to make this
all about me or my stand-up comedy
career which you can watch on Fox's
All-American New Year on December the
31st but the most seminal comedy special
of my youth was called Carlin on Campus
and George Carlin ordered an hour
special at a series of universities
because it was so risque at the time you
could only say stuff like this at
colleges so we've devolved that much in
terms of colleges being bashed into Free
Speech Carlin on Campus today would be
called Carlin on fire because they would
burn down the whole university as they
do to guys like you and I'm so amazed to
add to that that we're putting such an
emphasis on words in places like
Stanford where they have so many I mean
you can walk down the street in
California without getting attacked by a
homeless person or as they call them in
Stanford a free-range people but the
point is we're fighting the wrong
battles that's the point the jokes are
not violent speech is not violence I'm
an ex-cab driver you never got punched
in the head and said thank God that
wasn't a joke you know what I mean and
that's what we're getting wrong all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else